Now we'd like to
analyze in more depth
our result that for a
system of particles--
so let's indicate our system.
We had particle 1.
We have our jth particle.
And we have a
particle N. So here's
our system of particles
where the total force caused
the momentum of the system
of particles to change.
Now, I'd like to examine that
concept of the total force.
Before we said that our total
force on the jth particle--
we just wrote it like this.
And I'm going to put a little
t up here for the moment.
Because when we examine
what force we mean here--
and I also want to put a little
boundary around our system.
And let's now consider
another particle
internal to the system.
And let's try to
identify the types
of forces on the jth particle.
We can really have two
types of forces here.
Our first force can be an
interaction between these two
particles.
So what I'll write is the
force on the jth particle
due to the interaction between
the k and the jth particle.
And I'm going to put
a little sign up here.
I'm going to write
this internal.
What do I mean by internal?
This is a force strictly
between the internal particles
in the system.
Now, of course,
we know that there
must be a force on
the kth particle
due to the interaction between
the jth and the kth particle.
And we can call that internal.
So what we have
here is that we can
divide-- there can still be
other forces acting on the jth
particle.
And we'll do a
decomposition like this.
We'll say that the total
force on the jth particle
can come from some
external forces.
There could be an object
outside our system.
If these were interacting
gravitationally,
there could be a
planet outside here.
And this could be a moon.
And our system is
just the moons.
That would be an external
gravitational force,
plus the total internal forces.
So I'm going to keep
this same color.
Internal on the jth particle.
Now how do we write this
total internal force?
Well, we're interested in the
force on the jth particle.
But the internal forces can come
from all of the other particles
in the system.
So what we're looking at
here is for a sum over all
of the possible interactions
where the other particles, k,
go from 1 to N. And we have
to be very careful here that
in this sum k cannot
be equal to j.
Now this sum-- again, because
it's a little bit tricky
to understand-- is the internal
force on the jth particle.
Here's the kth one.
But this could be a sum.
I'll just draw one here.
This is the internal
force on the jth particle
due to particle number 1.
And so we're adding
as k goes from 1 to N
all of these internal forces.
But we're excluding
the case when
k equals j, because
that would be
a force of an object on itself.
And this quantity
here, we can write
as the total internal
force on the jth particle.
So in summary, we see that the
total force on the jth particle
is equal to the total
external forces.
I didn't say total there.
I'm assuming there could
be many different types
of internal forces plus
the total internal force.
A little bit later on,
we can drop the T's
for simplicity of notation.
But this is our big idea, that
a force on the jth particle,
external plus internal.
And now when we
look at this sum,
and we want to now
apply our main idea,
we have that the force, which
we're writing as-- let's
explore this.
Our total force is the sum of
the forces on the jth particle.
And we've now done
this decomposition.
I'm going to drop total.
So it's the sum of the external
forces on the jth particle.
j goes from 1 to N.
And here, we have a sum
of the internal forces.
So we have our sum j.
It goes from 1 to N of the
internal forces on the jth
particle.
Now we want to apply
Newton's second law.
And the concept is
very straightforward.
But the mathematical expression
can be a little bit messy.
We know by Newton's
second law that the sum
of a pair of internal
forces is zero-- third law,
by Newton's third law.
So what we're saying
here is, as an example,
for Newton's third
law-- let's just focus
on this particular pair-- that
F internal kj plus F internal jk
is zero.
So this is the statement
that internal forces
cancel in pairs.
And so when I look at this
total internal force, which
is the sum of all of these
pairs of internal forces,
I can see that the total
internal force has to be zero.
So internal force
cancel in pairs.
Now here, we can see
it another way if we
want to look at this notation.
We took the sum.
j goes from 1 to
N of F internal j.
Now we use our definition
for F internal.
This where things get
a little bit messy.
k goes from 1 to N.
k not equal to j.
j goes from 1 to
N. F internal kj.
This looks terribly messy.
But what we're saying is this
sum is just a sum of pairs.
And every single pair
in this adds to 0.
So what we have for
our statement now
is that the total force is the
sum of the external forces,
plus the sum of
the internal forces
which we've now said
that cancels in pairs.
So let's rewrite that as the
total force-- now instead
of writing this
sum, let's write it
as the sum of the
external forces.
And the internal
forces cancel in pairs.
And so this is now our
force on our system.
It's only the external force.
And now we can recast
our Newton's second law
for a system of particles
with the following statement
that the external force causes
the momentum of the system
to change.
And this becomes our expression
for Newton's second law
when we apply it to
a system of particles
where the beauty of this idea is
that no matter how complicated
the interaction is
inside the system,
all of those interactive
pairs sum to zero.
And so only thing that
matters is the external force
in terms of changing the
momentum of the system.
And now we'll look at
some applications of that.